esta es una de las formas más rápidas en
las que podemos resolver este tipo de
problemas de colisiones elásticas cuando
desconocemos las velocidades finales
conocemos la velocidad inicial de la
pelota de tenis y su masa así como la
velocidad final de la pelota de golf y
su masa pero desconocemos las
velocidades finales de ambas pelotas y
un truco para resolver más rápidamente
estos problemas de colisiones elásticas
es usar esta fórmula la velocidad de uno
de los objetos al inicio más la
velocidad de ese mismo objeto al final y
esto debe ser igual a la velocidad del
segundo objeto al inicio más la
velocidad de este segundo objeto al
final esto se cumple si tenemos una
colisión elástica y esto lo deducimos en
el vídeo anterior y ahora que ya lo
conocemos vamos a poderlo usar para
cualquier colisión elástica recordemos
que esto solo nos sirve para cuando
tenemos colisiones elásticas
si este es el caso ustedes van a amar
esta fórmula ya que nos evitará tener
términos cuadra ticos y mucho desorden
algebraico veamos cómo usarla digamos
que mi primer objeto es mi pelota de
tenis entonces voy a tener que la
velocidad de mi pelota de tenis inicial
más la velocidad de esta misma pelota de
tenis al final va a ser igual a la
velocidad de mi segundo objeto que va a
ser mi pelota de golf esto es igual a mi
velocidad de la pelota de golf inicial
más la velocidad de esta misma pelota
pero final y ahora vamos a ponerle los
números conozco la velocidad inicial de
mi pelota de tenis que es de 40 metros
por segundo a la derecha como es a la
derecha su signo es positivo por lo que
aquí voy a poner más 40 metros por
segundo
a esto le agrego mi velocidad final de
esta pelota de tenis que no conozco por
eso la sigo poniendo como variable
y esto va a ser igual a la velocidad
inicial de la pelota de golf que también
la conozco 50 metros por segundo pero va
a la izquierda estas son las velocidades
tienen que incluir la dirección así que
como hacia la izquierda es negativo esta
la voy a poner como menos 50 metros por
segundo y a esto le sumó la velocidad
final de esta pelota de golf que tampoco
conozco es importante no olvidar que
cada una de estas cantidades es una
cantidad vectorial por lo que tenemos
que indicar siempre su dirección ya que
una vez que resolvamos esto podríamos
tener cantidades o velocidades negativas
y si aquí quiero despejar mi velocidad
de la pelota de tenis final voy a restar
40 metros por segundo en ambos lados de
la igualdad por lo que me va a quedar
que esta velocidad de tenis final
es igual a menos 50 metros por segundo
menos 40 pues esto va a ser igual a
menos 90 metros por segundo más la
velocidad de la pelota de golf al final
y voy a cambiar de lugar algunos de los
elementos de esta fórmula para que
queden un poquito más ordenados aquí voy
a tener que mi velocidad final de la
pelota de golf que es positiva menos 90
metros por segundo lo único que hice fue
intercambiar de lugar esto
este término por sí solo no me es
suficiente para resolver mi problema ya
que es una ecuación que tiene dos
incógnitas tengo que usar otra ecuación
para poder resolverlo y la otra ecuación
que voy a usar es la de la conservación
del momento y puedo hacer esto porque si
yo tengo un intervalo de tiempo lo
suficientemente pequeño como para que no
pueda intervenir ninguna fuerza externa
el momento se va a conservar se va a
mantener constante así que el momento
total inicial debe ser igual a el
momento total final y esto lo vamos a
hacer casi para todos los problemas de
colisiones
estos son vectores no olvidar y
recordamos que podemos hacer esto porque
suponemos que el impulso externo total
va a ser tan pequeño porque el intervalo
de tiempo que estamos tomando en cuenta
aquí para esta colisión va a ser muy muy
muy pequeña la fórmula del momento es
masa por velocidad por lo que el momento
inicial de ésta
de tenis va a ser su masa 0.0 58
kilogramos por su velocidad inicial que
es de 40 metros por segundo ya esto le
tengo que sumar el momento inicial de la
pelota de golf que es lo mismo le sumó
la masa 0.0 45 por su velocidad inicial
que es de 50 metros por segundo esta
velocidad inicial es de menos 50 metros
por segundo porque va a la izquierda
recuerden que estas son cantidades
vectoriales por lo que tenemos que
respetar los signos que indican la
dirección este fue positivo porque su
dirección es a la derecha y este es
negativo porque su dirección es a la
izquierda todo lo que va hacia la
derecha será positivo y todo lo que va
hacia la izquierda será negativo y por
la conservación del momento esto debe
ser igual al momento final de mi pelota
de tenis que es la masa igual 0.0 58
kilogramos
pero como este es mi incógnita no
conozco la velocidad final voy a usar la
misma nomenclatura que tengo aquí
or be efe
y a esto le agrego el momento final de
la pelota de golf que igual va a ser su
masa 0.0 45 kilogramos por su velocidad
final que tampoco conozco y voy a usar
esta misma nomenclatura velocidad de la
pelota de golf final si yo hago los
cálculos para todo este lado izquierdo
me va a quedar que es igual a 0.07
kilogramos metros por segundo y esto va
a ser igual a esta expresión de acá que
voy a copiar y pegar
y en esta ecuación también tengo dos
incógnitas por lo que tampoco puedo
encontrar el valor de estas incógnitas
pero ahora ya tengo dos ecuaciones y dos
incógnitas y cuando tenemos esta
situación podemos despejar una de las
incógnitas y sustituirla en la otra
ecuación para dejar todo en términos de
una sola incógnita en otras palabras yo
conozco ahorita cuánto es
dt final y puedo tomar esta expresión y
sustituirla en la otra ecuación en el
lugar de bt efe y así tendré una sola
expresión en términos de la velocidad de
la pelota de golf al final vamos a
hacerlo aquí de este lado sigo teniendo
0.07 kilogramos metro por segundo de
este lado sigo teniendo el 0.0 58
kilogramos pero ahora está btf la voy a
reemplazar por lo que tengo aquí que
de g efe - 90 metros por segundo esto es
mi btf que sustituye de esta fórmula ya
esto le voy a sumar este término de acá
que es cero punto 0 45 kilogramos por b
y en este punto ustedes me pueden decir
a ver esto es fácil de todas maneras
tengo toda esta expresión que resolver
tuve que poner una ecuación dentro de
otra y ahora todavía tengo que resolver
todo esto bueno esto es fácil comparado
con lo que teníamos que hacer cuando
teníamos la conservación de la energía
cinética porque ahí teníamos elementos
al cuadrado así que además de hacer esto
tenemos que trabajar con elementos
cuadráticas que la verdad son un
desorden así que aunque no nos salvamos
de incluir una ecuación dentro de otra
estas ecuaciones con las que trabajamos
son mucho más sencillas que aquellas que
tienen que ver con la energía cinética
gracias a que conocemos esta ecuación
nos podemos ahorrar el usar la energía
cinética sino tendríamos que sustituir
esto en la fórmula de la energía
cinética que tiene todos los elementos
cuadra ticos con lo que el álgebra se
nos saldría un poco de las manos se
complicaría demasiado en cambio con esto
tengo puros elementos lineales
que puedo trabajar sin tanto problema
algebraica mente aquí sólo tenemos que
trabajar con las velocidades y ninguna
de estas velocidades está al cuadrado
por lo que nos simplifica mucho la vida
y de hecho aquí ya estamos a punto de
terminar lo único que tengo que hacer es
multiplicar esto por todo lo que se
encuentra aquí de manera que me sigue
quedando de este lado el 0.07 kilogramos
metro por segundo igual a éste
0.0 58 x deje efe
0.0 58 kilogramos por vejez efe - este
punto 0 58 por 90 con el signo negativo
aquí es importante no olvidar el signo
esto es 5.22 o menos 5 punto 22
kilogramos metro por segundo y aquí sigo
teniendo este más 0.0 45 kilogramos
efe y el paso clave por lo que hicimos
esto de sustituir una ecuación dentro de
otra es para tener una ecuación pero en
términos de una sola incógnita y aunque
aquí tengo dos términos con esta
variable lo que puede hacer es
combinarlos al menos son la misma
variable aquí tengo una parte de la
velocidad final de la pelota de golf y
aquí tengo otra parte de esa velocidad
final de la pelota de golf así que lo
que me va a quedar es de este lado
izquierdo sigue siendo lo mismo 0.07
kilogramos metros por segundo que es
igual y voy a reacomodar mis términos de
manera que ahora aquí tengo cero punto
cero 58 kilogramos de este término de gf
+
0.0 45 kilogramos todo esto va a estar
multiplicado por mi velocidad final de
la pelota de golf y a esto le restó este
término que queda menos 5 punto 22
kilogramos metro por segundo y si esto
les parece alguna brujería matemática no
se preocupen lo único que hice fue
agrupar estos términos que tienen bgf
porque si yo tengo puntos 058 bgf más
punto 0 45 de gf es lo mismo que tener
puntos 0 58 más punto 0 45 todo esto por
bg efe pero en este momento no traten de
dividir todo entre esto hay que ir en
orden primero vamos a tener que sumar 5
puntos 22 en ambos lados de la igualdad
para que esto se cancele así que si lo
hacemos me queda punto 0 7 más
a 5.22 me va a quedar 5.29 kilogramos
metros por segundo y esto me va a quedar
igual a esta suma que es 0.1 0 3
kilogramos
por mi velocidad de la pelota de golf
final y ahora si divido ambos lados
entre punto 103 kilogramos me va a
quedar 51.36 metros por segundo y esto
va a ser igual a la velocidad final de
la pelota de golf
y ahora por fin ya encontramos la
velocidad final de la pelota de golf
pero todavía no conozco la velocidad
final de la pelota de tenis como la voy
a encontrar bueno ya que conozco esta
velocidad final de la pelota de golf voy
a tomar este valor y lo voy a sustituir
aquí que fue la expresión que usamos
para incluir en esta otra ecuación así
que ahora finalmente puedo yo saber que
la velocidad final de mi pelota de tenis
va a ser igual a la velocidad de mi
pelota de golf la velocidad final que
fue de 51.36 metros por segundo menos
esta velocidad que ya tenía que es de 90
metros por segundo
hago esta operación y me va a quedar que
esta velocidad final de la pelota de
tenis es igual a menos 38.64 metros por
segundo esta es la velocidad final de mi
pelota de tenis y el signo negativo me
indica que debo
hacia atrás de ir a la derecha en el
momento de la colisión ahora va a ir
hacia la izquierda por eso tiene este
signo negativo y va a ir hacia la
izquierda a 38.64 metros por segundo en
resumen esta fórmula que nos permite
relacionar las velocidades iniciales y
finales en una colisión elástica y que
eso lo podemos usar para ecuaciones
elásticas y si quieren ver de dónde
salió esta ecuación los invito a que
vean el vídeo anterior de esta fórmula
despejamos una de las velocidades que
desconocemos y las sustituimos en la
fórmula de la conservación del momento
de manera que me quede una ecuación con
una incógnita
las agrupamos lo resolvemos y para
encontrar el valor de una de las
velocidades desconocidas y ahora con
este valor que encontré lo sustituyó en
mi otra ecuación de manera que ahora ya
puede encontrar el otro valor o la otra
velocidad desconocida y qué
esto es mucho más fácil que la
alternativa que involucra la energía
cinética y la energía cinética tiene
términos cuadra ticos que nos van a
complicar muchísimo el álgebra